To get our camera to zoom out so
we can see the whole star,
we need to set the camera's
viewport size.
So here we've set both the width and
height of the viewport to
be doubled the radius.
So the star should fit
comfortably in our camera.
Note the distinction between
these two lines, the setToOrtho
call tells the camera how big a window
we're using to look the world.
The viewport size is how much
of the world we are looking at.
Then we set the camera's position
to be the center of the star.
Let's see what it looks like.
Whoa, the star's all stretched out.
Let's see if we can figure
out why this happened.
So we set the viewport width and
height to be equal, but
our window doesn't have equal width and
height.
It's wider than it is tall.
Anticipating this occurrence,
we already calculated the aspect
ratio of the window up here.
Now we can just set the camera's
viewport width to be the aspect ratio
times the viewport height.
Let's try it now.
Much better.
I thought stars were
supposed to be circles.
Let's actually do one more thing and
nudge our camera to
the right a little bit, and
now we can see both the entire star and
the itty bitty planet next to it.
Let's try zooming in
on this planet next.
So we've set the viewport height
to be double the planet radius so
the window should just
contain the planet.
Then we set the viewport width to be
aspect ratio times the viewport height.
That way the planet stays a circle.
Finally, we just set the position of the
camera to be the center of the planet.
And there we go.
We've apparently got a very heavily
forested planet or something.
All right, let's do this one more time.
This time with the satellite.
So, setting the viewport height and
width should be pretty familiar,
and then we set the position.
let's see what we've got so far.
Cool, so we've located
the satellite out in space, but
looks like the satellite is rotating
as it orbits or something like that.
Let's match the rotation of our camera
to the rotation of the satellite.
So here we go.
The satellite's rotation is contained in
this constant, and then camera.rotate
will rotate the camera by that
number of degrees counterclockwise.
Let's give it a try.
Awesome, docking ports aligned.